it's a conversation piece but then also
the wow factor of how much it costs and
then you see the disposable income of
how wealthy some people are just to
collect art I love I love stuff like
that should we just make stuff for rich
people
[Music]
there is a handbag
that just sold for sixty three thousand
five hundred dollars it is a Louis
Vuitton handbag
guess how big it is
63 Grand 63 000. one of those little
yeah it's like a clutch it's like this
it's definitely a tiny one really let's
hold it yeah it is uh microscopic shut
the [__] up well you mean like what you
gotta look at it in a microscope so our
lady is going
to actually have to look at it you can't
even hold it like that [__]
oh yeah it looks like a pimple dude that
looked like something I found on the
concrete it's that little yellow thing
right there so what is it I was looking
at the cursor yeah yeah me too I was
like I was like oh it's smaller than the
cursor yeah
yeah it's right there there whoa if you
buy that you're a [__] [__] 63
000 [__] up dude if you have that
you're a [__] [__] dude you think
so yeah what if you lose it and you're
like honey can you get my purse I need
like an extra macro macro photo it's not
macro enough Bart paid 20 000 less for
blind what a [__] idiot at least that
has some sort of function is there a um
yeah yeah yeah it's like an artist I
don't have any more that's the couple to
stay with the house here it is under a
microscope
wow wow that's kind of cool oh that's
cool is that crazy that's pretty cool
that must be a high-powered microscope
you gotta [__] go zoom zoom that's
tight that's kind of crazy right that's
pretty cool that's [__] crazy you
should have got the LV on it oh it says
LV on it it's a Louis Vuitton wow what's
the point of that thing just to hold it
up yeah yeah I think it's how long did
it take you guys to do this because it's
not it's not made by Louis Vuitton it's
made by an art group
oh wait so they just copy it the same
dude to do the blood shoes the holy
water shoes they're called
m-s-c-h-f and uh yeah they oh they
designed it
um to be smaller than a grain of salt so
was it is it a collab it's it's not
they're not saying it's a collab it's
like a it's like a um a publicity yeah
yeah then why would you wait make it
like okay because we're talking about it
okay I mean and we're talking about
Louis Vuitton okay like the uh you know
the big red boots yeah yeah it's like
they made those two like everything they
make is like a statement wow that's
pretty cool so it's narrow enough to
pass through the eye of a needle it's so
small you need a microscope to see it
they say there's a big handbags normal
Handbags and small handbags but this is
the final word in bag miniaturization
Hey where's my bag where's my bag
and I don't know that it's functional it
doesn't say anything yeah [__] in there
you can put [__] atoms you could put
a grain of sand in there [__] flea
[__] in there you put a nucleus in there
a nucleus so bidding on the bag
um started at 15 grand and then it ends
up selling for 63 000. wow wow that's
cool I mean this is dumb [__] huh it's
crazy that there's people that are like
[Music]
I'll buy 50.
somebody's like oh so like two it's five
Waikiki is kind of the Rodeo Drive of
Hawaii right there's a lot of luxury
Brands and then sometimes ladies will
pull up
to June B with like five six shopping
bags of Hermes whoa each one of those
purses are like man that's like you're
just holding hundreds of thousands of
dollars that's what I'm saying it feels
so unsafe like you know those Birkins
like those [__] those bags are like
25k 35k hundreds of thousands if I was a
lady I would not want to be [__]
carrying that expensive thing around bro
why do you think there's so many Smash
and grabs for those damn bags man I mean
it's pretty safe but there's people out
there like with like multiple bags of
Louis Vuitton like all that there's like
all these big luxury Brands right and um
yeah like I found out that they make a
lot like hundreds of thousands of
dollars a day in sales that's one store
is making a hundred mil like it's crazy
yeah yeah same guys oh damn yeah yeah
they're based in Brooklyn and they do
like stunts like this yeah one of my
favorite bags this is REI I'm a big fan
of Aria you know they got lifetime
warranty they do that's what I love
about them they'll have life also have a
[__] ton because I also really like bags
and and [__] backpacks and duffel
bags and they have lifetime uh warranty
so even for no reason to you could just
see one that you like and you could just
bring your old one in and the no
questions that they'll swap it out
really do you think all the people that
looted it during the riots are doing
that just returning it and getting a new
shows the lines are that long for return
well REI does is they carry like the top
camping [__] yeah and what they do is
they study all of them so they take like
all the tech and they put it in their
own and then they offer it at an
affordable price that's cool so there's
just really really really really good
it's like Patagonia North Face type [__]
for like half the price and so people
stole all those things that makes me sad
do they have anything made out of photon
polymerization printing methods yeah
probably not because that's what this
shit's made out of yeah that's who's
printing on photons
resin with a gel case wow I wonder how
long it took them to create that
they just 3D printed it like oh [__] it
is what they did right they 3D printed
it in a way yeah yeah so what do the
photons come in bro what the [__] is a
photon how do you even print that photo
they just tell you that so that you know
how to correctly brag about it when it's
yours yeah this is my tiny little bag
it's got photons in it at the end of the
day isn't that kind of what it's about
yeah it's just getting to brag that you
have that oh yeah hey you know the news
story yeah I have it my [__] base
yeah that's exactly what it is but I
mean design and art is so trolley too I
know I love it a lot of this stuff is
like it's to start it's a conversation
piece but then also the wow factor of
how much it costs and then you see the
disposable income of how wealthy some
people are just to collect art I love I
love stuff like that should we just make
stuff for rich people yeah that's a good
[__] racket dude great business
Hunter Biden
let's just make some art and just sell
it to Old rich people you guys remember
how Wutang made an album that no one had
ever heard and they made it only to
exist for the one person that buys it
what Martin shkreli bought it you know
Martin shkreli oh yeah the guy that
hiked up medication
he bought it and he like wouldn't let
anyone hear it that's so [__] funny
so he played into it but I think I I
feel like it's gonna get released or
something but like it's just like a
blank he originally bought it like
everyone was hoping a person would buy
it and then just let everybody have it
so we could all enjoy it and [__] but
he's like nah I'm putting it in a
[__] case oh the guy who hiked up all
the medical prices what a [__] face
that's his whole brand dude yeah he's
like I am a [__] face he's [__] face
Tony Stark he's these [__]
Gatekeepers you probably think we'll
change his phone today on that one yeah
they're like yeah if you know nobody's
listening yo yo yo yo
that's how I feel about like you know
how like Nikki Nikki got into the
Beatles Big Time a couple years back
right and then she got like the the
biggest album with like all their
unreleased Studio tracks
it all sucks like the songs that we love
I like we love for a reason oh those
ones yeah yeah the unreleased uh ones
that like they were testing out like
it's like the long and winding space
yeah like what I don't need to hear this
[__] yeah like I'm hearing like a
they're just practicing yeah they just
letting the garbage bin pulled all the
files out and we're like all right let's
sell it yeah and so she actually hates
it she got this version because
sometimes those whack-ass songs play and
we think it's gonna be the right one
oh damn yeah
and you have like Ringo like coughing in
the background
like beetles like purists are just like
oh my God so Nikki has a little buyer's
remorse oh big time on that one yeah
some of that [__] like really fascinates
me like I just like going into luxury
stores so I look at the material and the
things that are being sold and I'm like
we gotta capture this is so genius
because people just don't know yeah like
they don't know that this is shitty
quality or some of this stuff is like
dude that is really bad but they're
marking it up crazy because of the name
brand so they've created a whole system
of like I guess trust with their
customers and brand recognition to where
like they can sell garbage at a premium
so it's mostly just branding it's the
the ability of their brand to be able to
hike something up for a premium price
that no that like a t-shirt like how
much can you upgrade a t-shirt yeah you
know what I mean like go to Nordstrom's
dude they think a lot yeah yeah but the
top stuff it's not even available for us
it's like the one that's made Handmade
by Artisans by Design miners that shit's
like the they get it in the store and
then the sales people call like their
own clientele that would come pick it up
and if they don't have it on display the
stuff that we see in the store that's
just like throw away mass produced yeah
right remember like 10 years ago when
like dudes wanted to look wet
like like you'd buy a T-shirt and it
looks wet yeah and you have jeans on it
looks wet yep the guys just look like
they do there's a little hair looks wet
yeah they're like like yeah either and
even the store they got it from his Wet
Seal yeah exactly oh yeah Wet Seal was a
huge one
it's a weird Trend I'm glad it's gone
it's two thousands on it yeah it was
shiny and wet 2010s yeah like the Ed
Hardy yeah wet as hell dude it just
looks soaked
so glossy yeah one of the funniest
things is how luxury Brands mostly have
employees that don't buy or can't buy
their own products they're selling and
they're always mad at you too yeah when
you go in there I have a buddy that
that'll if you want him to come on he'll
come he's a he's a dealer at McLaren
Beverly Hills wow he doesn't have a
McLaren but he can tell you everything
about it and he can sell it like nothing
yeah but he also I don't think would
ever buy one himself
[__] I do respect some of those Brands
um where uh I forgot where I was at and
I was like oh [__] I'm like damn you
could like afford that watch like
working here and he goes well they have
a thing where they want everyone to be
proud of the brand so employees get it
at 50 off oh that's cool and then I was
like well how do they prevent people
from working one day and leaving and
then just buying it for 50 off and they
have like some sort of like screening
process and you got to stay on for like
like yeah like I won't yeah let's do
that cool that's pretty cool because
then it's cool to see like like people
wearing it in the store yeah versus like
you're wearing like like a [__] like
a Casio and you're trying to sell a
Rolex well they want you to that is the
motivation they're like you're not
allowed to wear anything else so you
have to buy it at the same time I've
heard some other stores they'll have
loaners oh yeah it's like you're not
leaving that thing you just put it back
put it on to go work and then give it to
me yeah because some people still can't
afford the 50 off dude I knew a kid he
was like 19 years old right and we were
two minute a little bit
he had a [__] a mom who was like in
charge of Wells Fargo so he had an Aston
Martin like V12 Vanquish like when he's
like 19 years old the one from The
Italian Job and he was at my
ex-girlfriend's house with us right and
we were all just having like hang hang
sash time and when it was time to go
he's looking all over for his Aston
Martin Crystal Key oh no wow and it's a
50 000 key just for the [__] key it's
50 G's wow you can't find it anywhere oh
they know how to milk it oh yeah and I
was like I hope he [__] never find it
and he's panicking my mom's gonna kill
me my mom's gonna kill me that's why I
heard about luxury cars is like an oil
change is like 20 000 or something crazy
just so they can keep just uh and you
have to do more yeah this was just
optional though like he didn't have to
get the crystal key but he got it to be
a little [__] so he could go go
around say this is fifty thousand and
he's doing that I bet you one of the
[__] tuber scum that I was with
probably swiped it good well wasn't
there like a wasn't there an app that
cost like like a hundred grand or
something stupid yes and it just shows a
diamond on your phone and you could just
show it's like a purple diamond
I swear that was real yeah I can't
remember what it was like 10 G's or 10
G's and then like you can have this
purple diamond on your phone it's just
to show it I wish I was smarter to think
about it but it's not the second thing
is you can't sell it it's just there no
you just gotta constant people dude we
gotta just come on calm the really rich
people who can afford 10 20 000 yeah and
it doesn't hurt yeah I gotta change my
those are bottles because the best cons
are just exchanges like [__] bottle
service probably the best condoms oh my
God legit probably the best Carnival
ever which service bottle service oh
yeah because each one of those tables
are like a hundred grand a night best
con of all time you know it's the second
best kind of all time Top Golf yeah well
I love it though I love it I love being
conned bro a bottle of of Smirnoff a
Topgolf like a 12 bottle is four hundred
dollars
yeah there you go